why would we expect them to give to
forsake their mating strategy which is
to spread their seed
but then so is isn't that kind of an
unfair deal for men so then if if you
then why would you stay with that person
and cheat
if if the pers if the woman's not giving
you the youth and whatever whatever
why keep her there and cheat on her when
you can just leave and be with the youth
that you want that's my thing like i
don't understand
but i'm saying well is it fair that
women expect it over a certain age
that's the question
because you give your best years to
someone else
so she's like wait a minute she's
talking about going into a new
relationship yeah i know but if you go
into a new relationship and say this is
the car and the car has been used for
the last 15 years don't have a spy date
honestly speaking like who said that we
gave our best to someone else i don't
even know my maximum or my best probably
i never done to to no one my best
because i don't know i give honestly
someone before i don't know if i get the
maximum i can't i don't know maybe i'm
gonna find tomorrow man i'm gonna give
actually the best of myself who said
that i already gave to someone else it's
about what they think is the best it's
not about you because you're not the one
buying so the guy the guy i think is the
best
yes
men from that men from the ages of 20 to
80 all think that girls are the most
attractive around 22 to 24.
but like this is a man that cannot stand
on his own like honestly because
if you honestly think that he can't
stand on his own yeah because like they
actually mind about what other people
think because if you're telling me that
after like they might be shaming men for
their standards that's shame it's shame
and soul guilt need to be no that's just
my point of view i'm saying that i don't
even spy your day does this doesn't mean
that after because i had six year uh
relationship i gave my best to someone
i'll tell you why because you're saying
if you're a real man if you're a proper
man then you would think like me but
that that's shaming men for what they
want it doesn't it doesn't have to think
like me i just don't want to mend and
think in this way just give me alone do
you know what i mean i want to mend that
it comes with confidence say i'm going
to get the best of you
point like i'm not spying like just
because i'm 30 or
yeah do you think you determine what the
best years are do you think they
determine what the best years are i
think we pick each other we should we
should actually pick the best for us me
and the man also okay what do you think
i think it depends on the situation
it depends on your ages where you're
right in your life
obviously men prefer younger women so
what age ranges are we saying are their
best years
i mean
it's different for i didn't say an age
so you could say 40 you could say 45 you
could say 35 you could say 30. that's i
don't i don't tell the men what to do
45 on average men prefer younger women
and women prefer older yeah so i'm
guessing the man is older
so
so why wouldn't she expect monogamy like
is he going to go younger than the 40s
i'm saying okay i'm saying isn't that a
unfair deal for men because he's not
getting the things that men value
it depends on the age so say say you're
50 and you're going out with a 40 year
old like what would you want bro like
you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah
you should have went for a 30 year old
why did you go for the food that's
that's
but the question okay so the reason i
ask this is because i think a lot of
women would have better results if they
took that off the table but they think
they're a higher value than they are
because they're they're selling the same
price they had at 22 that they that they
are asking for at 35 45 even though
they're on sale they're on discount
because you're you're not as you're not
sorry
their value is they're getting less
value as they get older in the sexual
marketing more wise and more wisdom and
all that sort of an experience you're
getting everything you're evolving and
becoming better because
you're you're telling men what to think
i'm not telling you i'm saying in this
room i'm talking about now she can't
even say it with a straight face no no
i'm saying that you're saying value me
value me for my experience but like they
don't want that they don't care you just
said
that
your value is is dropping in the sexual
marketplace yes well sex isn't all that
you bring as a woman you bring more
things to them you bring more things
than just sex if it's just sex then go
have you do you wanna do you wanna marry
someone you can't have sex with no do
you wanna marry someone you can't have
something do you wanna marry do you
wanna marry me oh no
it starts it starts with such six is a
big part for women for women for women
not for men okay how big is sex to you
in a relationship well it's
it will play
it will keep me in a relationship
no honestly like one question
may i like do you had best sex with uh
like 18 20 years old girl or with a 30
35 40
women
i i don't really tend to rate sex like
that when i go into sex no because we're
saying that we're dropping by age so
from your point of view just do you know
i'm not saying you know what she's
saying is about men as a collective yeah
that's why what she's saying is correct
speaking to the matter bro yeah and what
she is saying is correct because when
women get to a certain age men do see
them as less valuable yeah why i'm
asking why because they had like she
said youth purity you
you automatically see a younger girl she
looks younger she looks more attractive
you think that you hope that she's
has less mileage than an older woman
so naturally your first thought is i'm
dealing with someone who hasn't been run
through who doesn't have a higher
mileage her face moves there's no like
botox foreheads right
so all of this now is it about going
into new relationships that's the point
i'm trying to get to yes is that what
you is that so so the point is okay if
you're coming to a guy
over a certain age is it fair to expect
monogamy when you gave your best ears to
someone else is that a fair deal is that
no i'm saying is that a fair deal for
men to be monogamous to you when some
other guy got your best years it's
unfair to assume that a woman's given
all her best years to someone else
because but you're telling men what to
value now i'm not telling men i'm saying
it's unfair to assume that a woman has
given her best to someone else okay so
that's like going up to guys and say
they're saying hey you know i like 22
year olds maybe maybe 27 22 to 27 that's
that's what i think is the best and then
you're going up to guys and saying well
that that's not my best years i think my
best years are 30. when they're like
[Music]
when you say um
what do you mean the most valuable the
most valuable but valuable in what way
and
the market wants it the most okay so
were you talking about bearing children
or bearing children the way you the
young girl bearing children the way you
look um less bodies
if someone is 40 and she's had less
bodies than a 20 year old and she looks
younger than the 20 year old who's more
valuable then
because because you're looking
you're looking for an extreme excitement
show me show me one more show show me
one show me one forty show me one 40
year old that looks younger than a 20
year old i'm 35.
honestly speaking you don't want 20.
in general
i people don't believe me when i say my
age so if a woman like myself who
doesn't look her age whose body count is
lower than a younger person who's been
run through as you're saying
would that mean that i'm less valuable
or more valuable than a younger girl who
looks older than me and has had more
bodies in in the marketplace you would
fall into an exception you would find
that men are extremely surprised
potentially to the point they probably
may not believe you but if we're talking
about a collective
most women will tell you that
from 18 to 25
they got the most attention from men and
after those years it dwindled and that
is the point she's making what she's
making is when you get to a certain age
you become less desirable
i can't believe it okay because you're
not a man you wouldn't relate because
you're not yeah but you are the
exception and that's why it's blowing
your mind well but even at 30 but
90 of your eggs are gone by 30. so guys
no i'm like what i'm not mom
because we want to do this
because okay okay
of your eggs are gone by 30. so if a
guy's looking for a wife he wants
someone that can give him kids so you're
less valuable because you are less
likely to give him kids and you are more
likely to lie about your body count so
you could say oh i have a low body count
but the guy's not going to believe he's
like 35 you've been in the streets for
15 years yeah okay
i don't see the sense in lying but i'm
speaking like i said i'm the exception
or whatever my eggs dwindling after 30.
i think that's really
awful to say that a woman's value is
less because her eggs i said in the
sexual marketplace okay well in the
sexual marketplace a woman's value is
less because of eggs whatever because
someone could be 18 or could be dying
lows with an illness and they can't have
kids ever or there's probably women that
don't even want to have children and
they're living their best life okay but
when you're when you're arguing when
you're arguing the extremes that means
you are because you don't have a good
argument because that's not the rule and
you know i'm i'm just i'm just throwing
it out there i'm just saying this is a
bit odd
go ahead can i just say that
i don't know why women just don't get it
because is it women or me could just say
means
with you you're not the only everyone to
say you i'd say you but i'm just saying
women as in general
because
it is because 35
right you can be looking good at 35 and
you can get with a man at 35 and say
you're gonna have
you're gonna get with this man you're
gonna have a five-year relationship with
him and then start having kids
think about your 35 you're gonna start
having kids at 40. it's not going to be
the same as somebody who is 20 being
with that man for five years and having
children it doesn't matter how good you
look it doesn't matter about your body
because you can't beat
biology mm-hmm
that's that's what's gonna happen no but
see this again like what you're saying
andy is
is a is a great point it's like women
don't get it and
the facts are it's like
women can come out and say i want
someone who's
six foot plus tool that drives a nice
german car that makes x amount of money